نفذ الحرس الثوري الايراني وضربات صاروخيه
وغارات بطائرات مسيرات ضد قاره تابعه
لاحزاب ايرانيه معارضه داخل اقليم كردستان
العراق وقال بيان باسم الحرس الثوري ان
ضربته الحلقه اضرارا كبيره بمن سماهم
الارهابيين التابعين لاستقبال العالمي في
كردستان العراق من جهتها اوضحت وسائل
اعلام ايرانيه ان اربعه صواريخ سقطت فجر
امس الاثنين على مقر الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني في محافظه اربيل
بالتزامن مع تعرض مقر حزبكم لا قرب
السليمانيه لهجمات لطائرات مسيره مفخخه
وقال العميد علي فداوي نائب القائد العام
للحرس الثوري الايراني ان ايران حذرت
الحكومه العراقيه وحكومه اقليم كردستان
العراق من انها ستستهدف مقرات من سماهم
اعداء الثوره ما دام الداخل الاراضي
العراقيه وتستهدف الشعب الايراني واضاف
انه على العراق اخراج تلك المجموعات من
اراضيه وان ايران لن تستهدف سياده ووحده
الاراضي العراقيه وانما ما قاره تلك
المجموعات المسلحه واتهم فداوي واشنطن وتل
ابيب بدعم هذه المجموعات وبالتامل على
بلاده واوضح ان القوات الايرانيه تقوم
بالرصد الاستخباراتى وتحديد اماكن
المسلحين قبل اي عمليه حتى لا تستهدف
المدنيين